if you think you can have a balanced
life as an entrepreneur that's just all
bull what I've learned about business
over all these years and all these deals
it's never as good as it sounds but it's
never as bad as it looks
this land is mine I screwed it up we'll
start again
hello belief nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from shark tank
investor Kevin O'Leary and my take on
his top ten rules for success volume 2
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well
enjoy
I was working once in an ice-cream
parlor when I was about 15 years old my
first real job and on the second day I
was asked to scrape the gum off between
the Mexican tiles on the floor and I
said to the woman who owned the storms
called the goose ice-cream parlor you
didn't hire me to spread gum you hired
me to scoop ice cream and this this girl
the shoe store across the way that's
looking at me I don't want to see her
you scraping the gum and she said what
are you talking about I own the store
I'll do anything I want when you get
down to your knees and scrape that gum I
said I'm not doing it she said you're
fired last job I ever had I owe that
woman everything I don't like to work
for people many of you would hear I hope
in here that there's nothing wrong with
it if you want to control your own
destiny you work for yourself that's how
it works I'm trying to inspire those of
you are on the tipping point take the
chance you're young go for it
there's nothing better than being able
to wake up in the morning 10 years or 20
years so now into whatever you like it
is about freedom that's what matters
I'm not saying the employees bad but
believe me being an entrepreneur is
better I'm a little ice
[Music]
unfortunately one of the great benefits
of technologies productivity one of the
big downsized it's incredibly
distracting people check their Twitter
account or they'll answer a Facebook
message or they'll do something that has
nothing to do with making money and the
reason you go to work in the morning is
to make money that's what you're there
for all the other wonderful things you
can do with your time are based on your
ability to create an income for yourself
and your family so why spend any time
doing all that crap which is distracting
and so that's the number one thing I
find in my companies is when you see
someone failing and you look at how they
manage their time you'll see right there
what's going on they're not focused on
what matters
last thing here we talked about your ear
meeting with Steve Jobs and I've heard a
lot of what Steve Jobs since he passed
away and people talk about he was so
unbelievably difficult and tough in a
way yes you what would you characterize
in that way yeah he was a prick yeah but
do you have to be that way to accomplish
what he's done you know I respect him
for the tremendous success and the
vision he had I was proud to work for
him because that's what I was doing
supplying education software I always
thought in person he could have been a
nicer guy but would that have changed
the outcome maybe he was a genius and I
remember him saying I asked him about
what maybe was just some market research
on this before we spent two million
dollars on a particular product we're
doing for reader rabbit he said we don't
do market research we tell them what
they want and I thought wow not only is
that arrogant but it's brilliant it and
it works right and so I said okay big
guy let's do it and it was very
successful
I said whatever you do somebody can do
it better you have to bring your a-game
in every single day there's nothing
unique about any one individual what you
need is their passion their ability to
execute to meet artists and exceed them
the minute you lose that ability in
capitalism you're gone
it's a fair trade the engine that makes
you rich can take it all the way from
you there are no guarantees I think
that's incredibly important
what's a deal that you missed that one
of your fellow sharks was able to secure
that you look back on and say wow I
didn't know that was going to work out
that well but it has proven to be a big
success and there is one and I remember
the moment it was a deal called sponge
daddy it was a yellow sponge with a
smile in its face and I thought what a
piece of crap this is the guy wanted
$500,000 for like 50% of it and Laurie
was beside me you know the queen of crap
as I like to say she'd get the
Junction's here and the she started
bidding on it and I looked over at her I
said are you out of your mind this thing
is a sponge
it's a sponge she said leave me alone no
Laurie I forbid you to do this I can't
watch you kill money like this this is a
shame you're going to teach America had
a waste cache he said shut up I'm doing
the deal and she did sponge daddy did 50
million in sales last year it's a little
piece of crap
I mean that taught me a but I have a lot
of respect for her now that shows you
the power of a shark tank platform
simple product simple message there's
actually a great corporate lesson to be
learned in watching shark taken and I
urge anybody that's listening to this
now to think about this for their own
career if you go back and look at 6
years of data of all the deals that got
funded regardless to what the product
was and this does not detail the outcome
of the company just the ones that got a
check from a shark what are the common
trades or threads it turns out there's
three in a hundred percent of the cases
the entrepreneur is able to articulate
the idea in 90 seconds or less here's a
sponge under cold water it's hard
scrapes eggs off plates under warm water
you can suppose silver again right very
simple number two it's usually a team
are able to articulate why they're the
right team to execute the business plan
they have a plan they tell you what it
is and they tell you why they are the
accredited you know managers for it
that's interesting you find it in every
case with a success
and here's the one that really matters
in a hundred percent of the cases the
entrepreneurs knew their numbers inside
out you ask them about break-even
analysis margin analysis market share
growth competition in every answer they
have it they nailed it it turns out in
corporate America today and I teach this
now you know I taught at Notre Dame and
MIT the graduating cohorts I explained
this to them when you're leading when
you want to be a leader you have to
articulate your idea in 90 seconds or
less you have to explain why you're the
right person to lead and above all you
have to know your numbers you can see it
happen on Shark Tank it works in the
real world too and frankly Shark Tank is
the real world because it's real capital
so I use that and I teach it and I think
everybody should think about that
explaining your vision clearly
succinctly in a short period of time is
up being really important if you think
you can have a balanced life as an
entrepreneur that's just all bull
there's some other guy would want your
customer that's working 25 hours a day
right that's what I found and so I don't
I don't even talk about that anymore
saying look it's a great you have to
decide it's a path you either going to
control your own destiny or you're going
to be an employee they're both they're
both noble one gives you time to be with
your family one gives you a more
balanced life and the other one is balls
to the wall and the reason you do it is
to eventually have personal freedom
because you've been successful and I
think most people in this room fall into
that second category balls to the wall
and going to make it or they're not and
that's why I come here because I was the
kindred spirit I like to see
entrepreneurs that are willing to risk
it all but but have to realize there is
no balance the reason you do and pursue
an entrepreneurial career is to provide
financial freedom one day for yourself
in your family the sacrifice is there's
no balance during the period you're
growing a business if you're successful
the reward is financial freedom which is
the essence I told the young
entrepreneurs don't do it for the greed
of money do it for financial freedom do
it for freedom make yourself free one
day so you can do whatever you wish with
your time and the only way you can do
that in our society is you have to be
well
and so the rewards of a great
entrepreneur they achieve that wealth
and they're free to do whatever they
wish which may be more entrepreneurship
you don't know if you're passionate and
you're successful you will wait them
you'll wake up one day rich it won't
really be going for the cash it must
happen to you everybody I talked to the
said success doesn't remember the day
they became a millionaire no idea not
important to them they remember winning
they remember building a business of
being successful again the pursuit of
freedom manifests itself in passion
that's really what it's about and my
exposure most of the business people
I've met the successful ones the CEOs or
whatever they are at their core
optimistic can you be a pessimist and be
a successful entrepreneur you have to be
optimistic I think you have to view the
world in a way that assumes success
otherwise you'll never have the energy
maybe not a pessimist but a skeptic is a
good thing to be because what I've
learned about business over all these
years and all these deals it's never as
good as it sounds but it's never as bad
as it looks either you know every day
I've got 32 portfolio companies now
something wildly bad is happening to one
of them and the cell phone rings at 6:00
in the morning and something
fantastically great is happening to
another one and it seems to me the
random serendipitous nature of it all is
really intriguing to me because if I
could only show the pessimistic or very
you know depressed entrepreneur that is
calling me saying oh my goodness we just
lost Walmart or whatever it is it's the
nightmare of their day versus we just
got Walmart on the other business well
I'm trying to get everybody in the same
universe to realize it's never as bad as
but never as good either you have to get
up in the morning go back to work great
entrepreneurs are able to delegate the
successful women CEOs are remarkably
good at this remarkably good at it and
the way it works is Sarah give giving
examples the way Sarah works she hire
somebody she sets a goal for 90 days and
gets out of their way gets completely
out of their way lets them achieve it if
they achieve it she moves them up the
organization if they don't they get
three tries until they're out if you
can't achieve your goals in business
that's what happens but her whole thing
is let them do the work themselves let
them figure it out I don't want to use
my time for it that's what I hired them
for how do you want to play if I think
Kevin O'Leary you know what I want you
to play for me I want you to think this
land is your land Oh classic pro-labor
political subversive song we are bring
the lyrical things I would I got on the
lyric so they'd never say business when
it court absolutely against everything I
am
remember this to publication
ready we're going to go
this land is mine I screwed it up a
start again that's how much I hate this
I thought it is your land this land is
my land from California
right let's try it again I want you to
sing with me - you're not getting away
with this
all right there we go this land is your
California log Island
this land was made for you and me
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed if you want to get your
pick of who I should profile next in the
top tens check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
amy schmittauer amy thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and doing that awesome podcast
on your channel and you tweeting it out
I appreciate all the support and I hope
you enjoyed the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
great entrepreneurs have a tremendous
amount of knowledge of what they're
selling they know a lot of it everything
but they better know a lot about what
they're selling you never want to be
caught explaining yourself and not
knowing your product that's because
you're so passionate you're spending all
your time doing it
that's exactly what matters I actually
think what motivates entrepreneurs is
fear of failure and it certainly
happened to me you start a deal it's not
working you work harder to make it work
you pivot you figure out what you're
doing wrong here a failure is is the is
the ultimate motivation and I think many
every entrepreneurs failures your job is
to go out into the world and understand
who you serve it is not your
responsibility to solve all the
society's problems you pay taxes to a
government to do that your job is to go
to war everyday and win to win market
share to solve the earth or competitors
walk on to steal their customers and to
take their profits and win that's your
job and to make profits for your
shareholders so they give you more
capital to create more jobs to be more
successful to pay more taxes to provide
the standard of living that we have in
America today your job is not to solve
everybody's problem is to solve your
customers problems your shareholders
problems your employees problems I'm
very distressed when people tell me a
business should give a third of its
profits to charity that's not gracious
it should give all of it to in
shareholders who then give to charity
think of all the great things that are
done today by the Bill Gates of the
world the warren buffett's of the world
the only reason they can do that is they
make money for their shareholders don't
get lost in this debate stay focused and
true to the mission
business is war you have to win and you
take the spoils with your profits and
you help your fellow man but first you
make money